e
donc aujourd'hui je viens vous parler de
mon et leurs phobies ou plus simplement
ce qu'on appelle la phobie des chats ces
petits êtres qui sont érigés en au rang
de stars qui sont qui font l'objet de
toutes les attentions et qui sait de
toute les fascinations m'horripile
m'exaspère avec leurs poils leur
miaulements et leurs griffes
elles ne font peur et je ne supporte pas
de les voir et pourtant si je vous
disais aussi que je travaille dans un
zoo avec de vrais grands chats sauvages
cette fois ci avec de vrais départs
devraient crocodile en fait rien ne me
prédestinait à à travailler dans un zoo
puisque j'ai fait une spécialisation
business administration et en management
et par la suite j'ai occupé des postes
qui sont plus en lien avec le marketing
la communication la gouvernance et la
gestion tout simplement ça me rappelle
la fameuse expression des aides il y
même que dans la célèbre pièce de
théâtre à la baraque mais lequel
ute l'adsl mais finalement quand j'ai
travaillé sur le projet du zoo à partir
de 2007 je me suis passionné pour le
projet et j'ai commencé à découvrir
qu'être responsable du zoo c'est de la
gestion de la gouvernance du marketing
et de la communication mais pas les peu
moi il était capital de dépasser ma peur
pour les animaux et de découvrir cette
semaine vétérinaire qui m'était
complètement inconnu donc là vous avez
le site une page du site web du jardin
zoologique avec tous les aspects
marketing et tout ça mais le reste le
monde animal m'effrayer beaucoup et j'ai
décidé avec l'équipe vétérinaire du
jardin zoologique de commencer à
découvrir ce monde et j'ai puisé dans le
voilà donc challenge excellent accès
petit et j'ai commencé à 20h marqué avec
les eaux internationaux pour comprendre
que la mission des zoos en fait c'était
le point de rencontre entre le besoin
des visiteurs en termes de
divertissement et de détente et en 2d
d'éducation à l'environnement
donc jusque là j'étais dans mon élément
mais après pour le bien-être des animaux
il fallait découvrir les aspects de
reproduction les aspects de recherche
scientifique et de la conservation et la
gélise et dans le matériel de management
pour aller faire une comparaison entre
la pyramide de maslow qui sans qu'ils
aient une pyramide à ses claques que
vous connaissez tous qui est la
hiérarchie des besoins des humains donc
besoin physiologique besoin de sécurité
besoin d'appartenance besoins des cimes
et besoin de s'accomplir pour faire où
est élaborée une pyramide qui est à une
pyramide à une configuration à quatre
niveaux pour les animaux donc avec le
premier niveau qui est l'alimentation
l'environnement la socialisation et
l'enrichissement
donc là je vais commencer avec
l'environnement puisque lors de la
construction du jardin zoologique
on a commencé par ce point là qui était
fondamental et s'il ya une leçon qui a
été retenu de l'ancien zoo de témara
c'était de bannir les cages et d'adopter
une approche naturaliste hic qui permet
à l'animal d'être dans son élément
naturel d'être dans des répliques de
l'environnement d'origine où il habitait
et qui prenne en compte
l'afl à l'animal le climat la canopée la
végétation l'eau la topographie et la
géologie de l'endroit et là je vais vous
passez une vidéo du zoo vue du ciel
donc c'est vraiment un habitat qui va
inspirer dans un contexte qui va
inspirer le respect et non pas la pitié
avec cinq écosystèmes naturels dans la
montagne de l'atlas pour les animaux
hénique du maroc savons également le
désert pour les guépards et les
antilopes saharienne la savane africaine
pour les lions pour les girafes les
rhinocéros les éléphants
comme nous avons privilégié dans la
construction les matériaux naturels les
barrières non visibles beaucoup de
végétation pour donner cet aspect
d'habitat naturel pour les animaux et
permettre aux visiteurs de plonger dans
l'environnement de l'animal
d'un côté comme permettre de l'autre
côté à l'animal de se sentir chez lui et
de favoriser sa reproduction et partant
sa conservation
donc là vous avez la partie marécages
pour les animaux aquatiques deuxième
niveau qui est l'alimentation
donc chaque repas obéit à des règles
d'hygiène de rationnement et de
nutrition qui sont très très stricte
donc par exemple pour un guépard ça va
être 600 g de poule et décortiqué donc
pas debout fèves pour les guépards il
faut qu'ils gardent la forme pour leur
production
un lien il va prendre entre trois et
sept kilos de viande par jour là on voit
comment les animaux sont nourris et
pendant les la ration alimentaire et
variées selon la saison donc on saison
froide et les taux augmentent et où une
saison en période de gestation pour les
femelles
comme elle est réduite pour pendant les
saisons d'accouplement troisième niveau
la socialisation donc un animal qui est
nourrie logis pardon nourris logés et
triste s'il reste seul et c'est pour
cela que nous avons pensé à nos animaux
en mettant un sex-shop rééquilibrer donc
un mal pour une femelle ou même plus
donc deux femelles aux trois femelles
mais parle inverse pas une femelle pour
plusieurs mâles
faites la nature mais en même temps mené
c'est de n'être plusieurs congénères
plusieurs individus du même groupe afin
de privilégier un comportement de
structures sociales de hiérarchie et
également afin de permettre à ces
animaux d'avoir un comportement naturel
de marquage de territoire de querelles
quand il s'agit de se disputer le statut
d'un nominaux et comme nous avons des
présentations qui sent des présentations
multi espèces pour les espèces
herbivores dont cloud aws avant d ici la
savane africaine où cohabitent les
zèbres watts ou si les autruches et les
élans de cannes 4e niveau qui est
l'enrichissement donc une fois qu'on a
offert le gîte et le couvert aux animaux
ouf une fois qu'on leur a offert de la
compagnie il sans lui quand même et
c'est pour cela que nous avons introduit
donc à l'instar des hommes modernes à
l'international que nous avons
introduites ce qu'on l'appelle les
haines les animations ou les activités
d'enrichissement
l'enrichissement c'est permettre à
l'animal de garder cet esprit cet
instinct sauvage d'aller chercher sa
nourriture d'aller voilà là on a mis la
nourriture dont des bottes de foin ou
ici on l'a mis dans un bloc de classe
donc l'animal essaie de casser ça pour
atteindre sa nourriture du jour il ya
aussi d'autres activités donc on essaie
d'introduire des animations des objets
dans les les l'exposition afin que
l'animal soit capable de fuir de
chercher à son alimentation de grimper
et de jouer avec ses congénères
donc l'objectif final pour nous donc
après la préservation la reproduction et
la conservation
l'objectif final c'est pour quelques
espèces de les réintroduire dans leur
milieu naturel
c'est ce qu'on a fait récemment en début
d'année 2015 avec les gazelles dama
mhorr donc on peut pas le faire
les lions par exemple pour les guépards
mais c'est ce qu'on l'a fait pour les
dames à mort on les organisons une
opération avec le haut commissariat aux
eaux et forêts et à la lutte contre la
désertification
certaines associations locales et des
organisations internationales pour
lâcher ses ces animaux dans la nature
avec un système de suivi par gps
là on peut le voir là la gazelle elle
met un gps sur le coup pour suivre son
livre sont l'évolution dans l'ana dans
la nature donc pour la pyramide je
reviens à cette histoire de pyramides
les gg exclut les deux derniers étages
de la pyramide de maslow qui sent dans
l'accomplissement de soi et le besoin
des cimes
c'est fait exprès parce que l'animal à
mon sens n'a pas n'a pas un atteint
passer ces niveaux là mais ce que j'ai
constaté en côtoyant tous les jours ces
animaux qui sont plus dans le moment
présent qui sent dans l'ici maintenant
et ça on soit c'est la plus belle
expression d'affirmation de soi et cette
expérience a été très enrichissante pour
moi parce que l'on seulement j'ai
découvert un monde qui m'étaient
inconnues mais ça m'a permis de dépasser
une ma phobie pour les animaux ma phobie
pour les félins et notamment les chats
et grâce à ça j'ai pu danser avec ma
peur danser avec les guépards ou du
moins à prendre des selphy avec avec eux
et je vous remercie